[Music]
Hello.
How are we doing?
All right. How's Yeah. How's the energy
level? We're
good. Good. Yes. Let's go. Let's go. Two
more. Two more.
My name is Kevin. I lead product at
Windsurf and I'm super excited to be
back here. Thank you so much Swix and
Ben. It's always a pleasure to come back
to AI Engineer Worlds Fair.
The velocity of our industry right now
is incredible. It's like being on a kite
on the ocean and we're really excited to
see where the winds are taking us.
A year ago, we didn't have Windsurf.
People were coding with autocomplete. No
one had heard of an agent. And now the
Windsour editor is being used by
millions and millions of people all
around the world. And hopefully this is
a larger number than last time. How many
people have heard of Windsurf? And how
many people have used Windsurf?
[Laughter]
Good numbers. Good numbers. We got to we
got to improve that.
And Windsurf itself has changed
immensely in the last six months since
its launch in November. We retired the
name Kodium because we decided to catch
this new wave.
which is by the way what we call our
next generation innovations in the
product. We call them waves. And in case
you missed it, we are now 10 waves in.
And some of the key waves we've been
really excited about web search, MCP
support, autogenerated memories. I was
supposed to do that. Autogenerated
memories, deploys, and parallel agents
to name just a few.
And as the waves keep growing, as do the
number of people that have discovered
and integrated Windsurf into their daily
workflows. To this day, we are
generating about 90 million lines of
code every single day. And that equates
to around a thousand over a thousand
messages sent every single minute. But
today is not about growth. I'm not going
to sit here and tell you about the
numbers. I'm going to tell you about the
why. Why do people feel connected to the
Windsurf editor?
And I know no AI company really wants to
disclose its secrets, but I had to come
up with some content.
So today, I'm going to let you in on one
of ours.
Our secret sauce is a shared timeline
between the human and the AI. And this
is what makes people feel like we're
reading their minds.
And now everything you do as a software
engineer can be thought of on this
shared timeline. So if we rewind way
back to the dark days, this is
pre-automplete when everyone knew how to
write a for loop. AI had to do
everything. You had to edit files. You
had to type every single character.
Imagine that. But then once services
like C-Pilot, like
they launched, then devs got really
excited. They started seeing a small
percentage of their code being written
by AI. And we started to abstract and
accelerate the number of small edits,
small actions that we would do for a
user. And in late 2024, with the advent
of Windsor's agent and the launch of the
Windsorf editor, we saw that we could do
more and more for the user. We started
being able to edit multiple files at
once, perform background research across
thousands and thousands of files, and
execute terminal commands directly
inside the editor.
But at Windsurf,
we're in the business of trying to
change how software gets created. And
this means that the timeline is actually
a little bit more complicated. It needs
to handle actions taken outside of just
the IDE.
And so given how much of a developer's
workflow happens outside of the editor,
what does this mean for Windsurf?
First, Windsurf is going to be
everywhere.
Specifically, Windinsurf will need to be
able to read and ingest context from
every single source that a developer
uses.
And if we zoom out and think about what
makes you all software engineers
successful, there are a couple of
different categories. The first of which
coding related file reads, running
terminal commands, seeing your history,
even you know which tabs you have open
inside of your editor. This all informs
how to generate the correct code. But it
goes beyond that. There's external
sources. Things like going on to GitHub
and viewing a past history of commits.
maybe looking at a PR that is doing
something similar to the feature you're
about to implement, doing online
searches, web searches, looking at
documentation.
And then there's the third category and
this is where it gets a little bit
interesting. It's called metalarning.
It's the idea of what separates a junior
engineer from a senior engineer from a
staff engineer. These are the
organizational best practices, the
engineering preferences that all get
encoded into what makes good code.
And so if we think about what this means
in practice, let's say that we are going
to build a new page on a data viz
dashboard. Let's walk through step by
step. So first you would probably start
in Slack as all good things start from
Slack. You'll build context looking at a
bunch of maybe customer requests. Maybe
you'll have some internal messages.
You'll collect that context and you'll
start planning. And this means you're
going to be in Google Docs. You're going
to be writing design docs, probably
working on some infrastructure designs.
You're going to be tracking tickets
inside of Jira. And then you might have
a designer who's actually working in
Figma in parallel putting together all
this material. And then finally, the fun
part, at least this is my favorite part,
which is the actual writing of the code.
And hopefully you use something like
Windsurf to do so.
But you're not done from there. Once
your code's complete, you still have to
open the PR. You got to get reviews. You
got to merge into main. You got to
deploy SEO analytics. The list goes on
and on and on.
And this is really why we've built what
we've built because we know that for you
it's extremely important that we can
fetch context from your Google Docs,
that we can read your Figma files, and
that we can oneclick connect to any MCP
service so that you can access your
information in things like Notion,
Linear, Stripe, and countless others.
And we've spent the last 10 waves making
sure that Windinsurf can be ubiquitous.
But we know that's also not enough.
We know it's not enough just to read. We
need to be able to do and write
everything. We need to be able to do it
all for you.
And so the AI has to take action on a
wide variety of surfaces beyond just the
coding surface in order to accomplish
what a human software engineer would do.
And so this doesn't mean just write
code. This means interacting with
thirdparty services, provisioning API
keys, writing design docs, PRDs,
wireframing, testing, and the list could
go on and on and on. And so for the last
6 months, we've oriented ourselves
around how do we do everything.
And if we go back to this concrete
example of building a new web app,
where do we start? We start by running
codebase relevant terminal commands.
This is something that we launched right
at the advent of Windinssurf. And what's
really cool about what we can do here is
that we can intelligently decide which
commands we want to run automatically
and which ones we want to wait and ask
for explicit user approval.
Next, you'll open up Windsurf browser
previews which allows you to iterate
from there. Allows you to visually
iterate with the agent so that Windsurf
can take control of Chrome just like you
would inspecting DOM elements, looking
at your JS console, being able to do
what a web developer would do.
And so now you could say our app is code
complete. We'll use the GitHub MCP to
open up a pull request. And we can use
context from your other PRs to be able
to inform the description and inform the
test plan.
And code review is still a necessary
part of any software company. And so we
launched windsurf reviews which can
automatically leave comments and suggest
changes asynchronously so that you can
be confident that the code that hits
main is production ready.
And so now that your code is merged,
you'll want to be able to deploy. And so
we also released a one-click service to
Netlefi so that you can use Windsurf's
custom tool integrations to actually
just in one click the agent will deploy
what you have to the live web.
And so as you can see, we've really
built the ability for Windinsurf to read
everything that you can and do
everything or almost everything that a
software engineer can. So then you might
ask, what's next?
It's only inevitable that Windsurf will
be on all the time working for you even
when you don't know it.
We pioneered the agentic human in the
loop synchronous workflows back when we
released Windsurf in 2024. And today
timelines are 80 to 90% agent, 10 to 20%
human. But we're trying to build towards
a future that gets the 99% agent and 1%
human. We only want to ask the user for
final approval. And as more and more of
these timelines and workflows become AI
powered, it becomes possible to have
WinSurf working for you at all times.
Not only as you type and use
autocomplete and tab, but also in the
background, researching when you're
working fully in parallel, only asking
you to approve.
And we want to build this future where
you can code anytime. You can write
software at any time. This includes your
bed. includes a toilet when you're on
the bus, voice activated Alexa. The
possibilities are endless.
And so now that we've defined the
problem, it's a little bit more
structured. You could say, "All right,
we'll throw GPT, we'll throw Gemini at
this timeline problem, but then from
there, where do we go? How do we
improve?" And specifically, how is
WinSurf able to tackle this problem of
the timeline?
And if we take a step back,
this really doesn't look like we're
writing code anymore. This looks
significantly more complicated than your
average competitive programming
question.
Windsurf wants to revolutionize the way
that software gets built. It's not just
how code gets written. We are solving a
broader set of tasks than just code. And
while the industry focuses heavily on
things like Swebench, we know that the
future is not going to be tokens in
tokens out. Software engineering
workflows are going to be much messier
than this. It means that you have to be
able to pick up tasks midworkflow. You
have to be able to deal with messy
codebase states mid commit. And you will
have to work with tools that are outside
of the editor.
And so we have to be able to ingest and
perform over this broad set of actions
on this timeline to keep our users in
the flow. We have to be able to open up
PRs. We have to know when to access
analytics. We need to know how to debug
your CI/CD all by itself. And this
problem starts to look really really
different from what people are evaling
on. And because we have our own
representation of this timeline, we
needed a different system to be able to
handle these types of actions than what
the off-the-shelf frontier models could
give us.
And so where are we going with this?
The realization of this is on our brand
new software engineering model called 1.
We realized ourselves that we could
actually dream bigger and build the best
software engineering model that we
could.
One is trained to handle software
engineering workflows, not just purely
code generation. And we use two main
offline eval benchmarks. The first one
end to end toend task benchmark. This is
basically tackling pull requests. This
is saying given an intent, given the
starting point of a codebase, how do we
get to the end and pass all the unit
test familiar paired?
The second one is where it gets a little
bit more interesting. This is what we
call the conversational suite task
benchmark. And this is how well the
model can assist when it's being dropped
into an existing user conversation or a
partially completed task. And so this
actually lends itself very nicely to the
windsurf paradigm, right? because we're
not going cleanly from start to end.
We're assisting in helping you along the
way midtimeline. And so it results in
this blended score of helpfulness,
efficiency, and correctness and really
tests the model's ability to seamlessly
integrate into the windsurf style of
working. And this initial performance
really gives us a lot of confidence in
SU1's architecture,
specifically how we've been able to
train for software engineering
workflows. And we've been able to achie
achieve near frontier model results at
the fraction of the cost and with a
significantly smaller team.
And one of Winserf's greatest strengths
of course is in the value of community.
Real software engineers doing real work,
giving real feedback. And what we found
is that Sui 1, it's in the little drop
down for the models. It's right up there
with the rest of the frontier models.
People are choosing SUI 1 because it
recognizes how they do work, not
necessarily how to generate code and
it's contributing actually an even
higher frequency than models like 3.7
and 3.5.
Windsurf builds at the frontier so that
our users can build more with the best
technology. We learn from our failure
modes so that we can iterate from there.
And what does this start to look like?
dare I say it, a data flywheel.
We ship the best product. Devs and
non-devs use that product to level up as
a skill multiplier or as a skill
enabler.
Users then help us find the frontier.
They use things like thumbs up, thumbs
down, accept, reject, constantly
informing us not of what the SWEBench
frontier is, but what is the software
engineering frontier? What tools are
missing? Which workflows are repeated?
Where does the product fall short?
And we take those insights and we build
at this frontier.
We train a better model. We build more
tools. We improve our agentic harness.
We improve our memories, our
checkpointing with the goal of being
everywhere doing anything.
And we will repeat this cycle. We will
be shipping, finding the frontier,
building at the margin, and repeating.
And what gets me really personally
excited about this is Sweet One is
really an example of this in action. We
have a very small team,
significantly fewer resources than the
larger companies, and we were able to
achieve near- frontier model quality
results with Sweet One.
And even more so, this is really a
demonstration of what it means to build
AI products in 2025.
It demands this harmony of model, data,
and application where the application is
actually mimicking the user behavior
that you want to replicate inside of
your model.
And this is how Windsurf will be
everywhere doing everything all at once.
Thank you so much for listening.
[Applause]
And I won't give you any promises, but
someone made a profit. Um,
but in all seriousness, thank you so
much for listening. I want to make sure
that every engineer out there is using
the best possible tools. So, please give
Winer a try today. And we are also
hiring across a number of different
roles. We have a booth downstairs, so
please come join us. help make this
future a reality.
Thank you.
[Music]